はい まああまり人のことをガチャガチャ悪口言ったって意味がないんだから
まあもう早く仏教の話に入ります
なぜ悪魔が登場するのかという
まあ善悪の実体を発見していない
人間というのは この善悪って何なのかとわからないんです
規則に従わない人間 宗教家がいろいろ目的があって規則規律を決めてしまいます
勝手に決めるんです しかし
人々は従いたくはないんです
例えば 旧約聖書で十戒がありますけど
誰も守ってないんです
その代わりに我々に説教するんです
宗教家も自分が決めた規則であっても破るんです
宗教家さえも自分が決めて書いたのに
これやるなかれ あれやるなかれとか破ってます
だから答えは良いことは難しいんですよ
悪は犯しやすいんです
悪魔の仕業にしてしまったんです
だから 例えば宗教の人がいる
本人が一生懸命本を文章を書いて
人間はこうであるべきとかね
いかなる場合でも嘘をつくべきではないとかね
人を助けてあげるべき
いろいろ言うなら 自分がやってないんです
自分は何のことなく嘘をついたりする
それで本人が驚き あら
なんだこれはと 私はそう思ってないのに
なんでやってるのかと
あ やっぱり自分の力と違う何か力に自分が支配されていると
だから私は嘘をついてるんじゃなくて
嘘をつかされているんだと
ということになるんです
だから聖戦が成り立つのです
人 生命は戦いたい 殺し合いたい
殺し合いをしたい しかし
良いこととして見えない
生命っていうのは 大体生命たるものはもう殺し合いやってますよ
殺し合いやってますけど
あまりいいこととは感じないんですね
結果として 完全に悪しき者がいて
またその者に従順する仲間もいるならば
戦いは正当化できるんです
聖なる戦いになるんです
人間が人を殺したい 動物もな
もう相手をもう何のことちゅうちゅうなく殺したいんです
しかし 殺して殴って怪我させていく生き方が
結局あんまりいい生き方だとは自分でも思わないんですね
でも 歴史の中で殺すことこそ素晴らしいやという文化は結構ありましたけど
もう残酷に殺して殺していくとかね
そういうことで もし頭の中でこの殺す相手が
殺される側が完全に悪い
もう話にならない いてはならないということを証明できれば
気楽に殺されます 気楽に殺せます
悪い人であっても やっぱりいろいろいいところもあるんだなとわかっちゃうと殺せないんですよ
だから この自分の戦い本能をに油をかけるために
油を差すために 完全たる悪しきもの
悪しきの悪の存在が必要になるのです
そういうわけで 悪魔との戦い
悪い人と戦うことは聖戦になってしまっている
だから平気で殺され殺せます
人々の闘争本脳に信仰の鎧をかぶらせてあげているのです